y vamos directo hasta parís la ciudad
luz para revisar las noticias de francia
desde nuestra redacción con esta
periodista erika olavarría erika muy
buen día finalmente ya estrenamos
directo américa ya se reunieron ayer
pero en nueva york los responsables de
los exteriores de eeuu y francia al
margen de la crisis de los submarinos
siguen disminuyendo las tensiones tras
la llamada de bailén y macro américa le
preguntó
y como le decía yo ayer era simplemente
el comienzo de la distensión esa reunión
telefónica que tuvieron los presidentes
de estados unidos y de francia ayer
durante una hora los cancilleres se
reunieron en la oficina francesa en la
sede de naciones unidas en nueva york
raúl y obviamente atrás de este
encuentro ambos coincidieron en que
queda todavía mucho para superar esta
crisis que ambas partes tienen que tomar
muchas acciones hay que decir que ambos
cancilleres se conocen ya desde el año
2012 cuando trabajaban para françois
hollande el francés y para barack obama
además anthony blinken el canciller
americano es un franco filo él vivió en
este país terminó aquí y su educación
secundaria habla perfecto francés por lo
tanto eso será un punto a favor de la
superación de esta crisis ambos lo
reconocieron van a estar en contacto
estrecho y van a estar haciendo y
tomando medidas sobre todo haciendo la
lista de esos temas que recordamos van a
entrar en esas conversaciones en
profundidad que acordaron el presidente
baiden y el presidente matrón en esa
llamada telefónica y prácticamente otra
llamada telefónica sí si el presidente
manuel macro no estuvo con el presidente
del consejo de ministros del líbano
hablaron
si simplemente le quería decir que
también una conversación telefónica
entre el presidente macro y el primer
ministro británico de boris johnson
también sobre la crisis de los
submarinos y de esta alianza ocu pero
realmente para francia lo más importante
es arreglar las cosas con eeuu y si el
presidente manuel macro no se acaba de
reunir con el nuevo primer ministro del
líbano otra vez este país está
intentando superar la crisis económica y
en general política que lo afecta
durante tantos años nayik mikati y que
le dijo el presidente matrón lo mismo
que le dijo a la unión europea que tiene
que hacer reformas para poder sacar a
este país de la crisis de entre las
muchas reformas hay también un acuerdo
con el fondo monetario internacional
raúl obviamente que es la intención
también del nuevo primer ministro
libanés cambiamos a otra noticia de
actualidad en francia a erika porque ya
nissan los anuncios que dejará de usar
pieles está siguiendo entonces a las
denuncias de maltrato animal
sin más que eso es una tendencia que hay
en la moda iff salón la marca forma
parte del grupo que vino junto a sanz
luego de las últimas marcas de este
grupo tan importante del lujo francés
que seguía vendiendo pieles de animales
todas las otras marcas del grupo ya
habían dejado de hacerlo según los
responsables de la marca es una
tendencia con respecto a las ideas que
están en boga actualmente dijo la
responsable de medio ambiente de caring
que no se podía matar animales no para
comerlos sino que para utilizar
simplemente su piel su cuero y por lo
tanto es una manera no es cierto también
de responder a esas presiones que tenían
de algunas personas de la organización
peta no cierto los animalistas que en
marzo habían marchado frente algunas de
las boutiques a logan porque había una
publicidad con kate moss que se le veía
utilizando la modelo británica no ser
que usted la conoce que se veía
utilizando un abrigo de piel de zorro
hay que decir que la fundación de la
actriz brigitte bardot se mostró muy
contenta por esta decisión de salón y
llamó la atención de otro grupo francés
del grupo el m los de louis vuitton que
todavía ellos trabajan con pieles de
animales raúl vamos a ver qué pasa si se
siguen sumando más casas de moda a erika
muchísimas gracias feliz fin de semana
los demás lunes con más información
desde parís nosotros regresamos a bogotá